my people the who must lay him off
people we've been here we never gave up
any of this land we never sold it we
never signed any of it away
myself I do have a place I do live in
SRO single-room occupancy are infested
with bedbugs and cockroaches and night
number one tool used by the government
against First Nations people is poverty
poverty keeps us where we are a lot of
our people believe now as I did until
very recently that we have no value and
now the First Nations people not only
are we coming back into our own and
finding our own power within ourselves
but we are uniting and we will continue
to speak the truth and we will not stop
subscribe on YouTube follow us on
Twitter and like us on Facebook